originally introduced in 1966 in one of
the most memorable moments in spider-man
history Mary Jane has had a career on
the page that's almost as complicated as
a radioactive boyfriend's from a comic
book origins to her on-screen
adaptations here's the untold truth
behind Mary Jane Watson while she
wouldn't make her first appearance until
December 1966 Mary Jane was first
mentioned more than two years earlier it
was actually a running gag in the comic
with Aunt May constantly trying to
wrangle Peter into a blind date with the
niece of her next-door neighbor and
Peter making every excuse he could to
duck out and avoid actually meeting her
the joke of course was that Peter
assumed anyone who needed their aged
aunt to set them up on a blind date was
to put it charitably probably not the
most desirable person for a relationship
for the record
Peter was also someone who needed his
elderly aunt to set him up on dates
finally after 27 issues of MJ looming
ominously like a go-go dancing sword of
damocles came amazing spider-man number
42 from Stanley and John Romita senior
after a relatively forgettable fight
between spider-man and hero astronauts
and future werewolf Space God John
Jameson Mary Jane Watson made her first
full appearance and we finally got the
punchline it turned out that MJ was
actually hot putting aside to slightly
sketchy more a lesson about keeping an
open mind because people you haven't met
might be physically attractive Mary
Jane's appearance marked a huge shift in
the spider-man dynamic for the first few
years of her existence Mary Jane's major
effect on the amazing spider-man comics
was to convert a love triangle into
something that looked a little more like
a rhombus
she was pitted against Gwen Stacy Peter
Parker's long-established dream girl
competing for peter's affection and
settling for double dates with peter's
roommate and future green goblin Harry
Osborn Gwen for her part had been
introduced way back in the early days by
spider-man's co-creators Stan Lee and
Steve Ditko in her original appearances
Gwen was a very different sort of love
interest a brilliant science student
with a short temper who often found
self bickering with theater and trading
sharp quips as their romantic tension
grew all that changed when Ditko left
the book and Romita stepped in as
Ditko's replacement and arguably became
the definitive artist of the era the
main change came from bringing his
experience from doing romance comics at
DC and he transforms Peter from an
awkward angular teenager to a handsome
college student Romita applied the same
style to the rest of the cast when
started spending a lot of time in go-go
boots and mini dresses and MJ earned her
reputation as the consummate party girl
right up until the Green Goblin changed
Spidey supporting cast forever amazing
spider-man number 121 will live in
infamy for being as the title of the
issue revealed on its very last page the
night Gwen Stacy died if you're even
passingly familiar with spider-man's
history you know how this one goes after
discovering Spidey's secret identity the
Green Goblin kidnaps Glynn and winds up
tossing her off the George Washington
Bridge and when Spiderman snags her with
a web line in an attempt to save her
life
he accidentally snaps her neck it was a
huge shift for the spider-man saga and
it remains one of the most important
deaths in Marvel Comics history and
along with Uncle Ben's it's one of the
few that's been carved into stone and
never undone what's often overlooked
though is that the issue that followed
represented a change that was almost as
big and not just because the Goblin
himself died after Gwen's death Mary
Jane shows up at Peter's apartment and
in his grief
Peter snaps at her offering some
extremely harsh comments about MJ's
seemingly shallow personality when he
tells her to leave though Mary Jane
chooses to stay and help him through the
tragedy it was the first sign readers
got that MJ was a little deeper than
we'd been led to believe
and it also hinted at a major reveal
that wouldn't hit the page for another
16 years in 1989 Marvel published
amazing spider-man parallel lives an
oversized graphic novel focusing on
Peter and Mary Jane as they grow up and
the ways
their lives intersect over the course of
flashbacks the story reveals that Mary
Jane had taken a keen interest in
spider-man from the very beginning her
fascination only increased on the night
that Ben Parker was shot when she looked
out the window of her aunt's house and
saw spider-man climbing out of her
neighbor's window she immediately
realized that Peter Parker was
spider-man and comic book fans suddenly
realized that MJ had always known about
his secret identity instead of being the
blind date that Aunt May and Anna Watson
had worked so hard to set up Mary Jane
had a new context as someone who pursued
Peter herself it wasn't because of a
misguided obsession with Spidey or
because she had a thing for superheroes
instead it was because she found a
parallel get it between the way he wore
a mask and kept his heroic identity
separate from the tragedies of his
personal life and the way that she had
always affected that flighty shallow
persona to mask the trauma of her
abusive upbringing more than anything
else the idea that she'd kept Peters
identity a secret for years without him
even knowing it put her in a completely
different class than any other love
interest in spider-man history in a lot
of ways the spider-man saga is about
watching Peter Parker grow up he starts
his super heroic career as a high school
student who lets his bitterness at being
a social outcast caused him to give in
to selfishness you could've taken that
guy apart now he's gonna get away with
my money I missed the part where that's
my problem he then has to deal with the
consequences of those actions over the
next few years
readers saw him stand up to a bully get
a job and deal with all the other
milestones of adulthood most folks go
through even if they don't fight Doctor
Octopus and the lizard in between in
1987 Peter and Mary Jane reached the
next big life milestone together when
they were married on the steps of New
York City Hall in amazing spider-man
annual number 21 the thing is it almost
didn't happen
at least in the context of historic even
once they realized they wanted to be
married and even after Peter proposed
twice they both still had a lot of
doubts that was what made amazing
spider-man annual number 21 such an
interesting comic plenty of superhero
weddings feature villains showing up but
this story was focused on Peter trying
to decide
if he should break things off with MJ
herself being tempted to run away with
the famous actor in the end of course
the two got hitched as for the
real-world reason behind the wedding
Stanley claims credit for coming up with
it as a publicity stunt and also
performed a live-action version of it at
Shea Stadium the wedding also happened
in the Spiderman newspaper strip that
Leigh was writing with an extra detail
that version of the marriage was
dedicated to fashion designer Willie
Smith who created Mary Jane's wedding
dress and appeared in the annual sadly
he would died of aids-related illnesses
at the age of 39 shortly before the
issue was published for years it was
rumored that higher-ups at Marvel Comics
wanted to get rid of Mary Jane and
Peter's marriage due to worries about it
making him seem old the problem was that
they didn't want to be stuck with the
spider-man who had been widowed or
divorced which would make him seem even
older than the marriage did my wife and
I split up but I handled it like a champ
it was a tough problem but eventually
they came up with a simple elegant
solution just have somebody make a deal
with the devil like literally the
literal devil now
really it happened in the aftermath of
civil war a crossover that among other
things had spider-man publicly revealed
his secret identity which immediately
led to Aunt May getting shot by a hitman
in order to save Aunt May and put the
secret back into Peters secret identity
Peter and MJ essentially sold their
marriage to Mephisto the Marvel
Universe's most stalwart stand-in for
Satan in a story called one more day
the second weirdest thing about this
other than the part where spider-man and
his wife were making Faustian bargain z'
was that it didn't disrupt continuity
all that much the official company line
was that every spider-man's story that
had taken place during the married years
it still happened the only thing that
had been retro actively changed was the
wedding itself the post one more day
idea was that all of the couple's
previous doubts had actually gotten to
them and while they kept on living
together they just never tied the knot
actually no the real weirdest thing was
that just as it had with the wedding the
newspaper strip attempted to do the same
but those readers hate change even more
than superhero comic readers do and the
reaction was so bad that the new
storyline only lasted a short time
before it was all Rhett conned into just
being a weird dream in the newspapers
spider-man and MJ are still happily
married if you're less than 4 degrees of
separation away from Peter Parker the
odds are pretty good that you've been a
superhero a supervillain or both at some
point in your life his college roommate
became the Green Goblin
and his science teacher was the jackal a
co-worker became venom 2 other
co-workers for both the Hobgoblin at
various times and one of them was also
another Green Goblin his bosses son was
a space werewolf even atmae was once
taken into space and reborn as golden
oldie Herald of Galactus the one big
exception Mary Jane Watson despite being
in close proximity to spider-man for
over 50 years of real time comics MJ
never got any superpowers of her own the
only big exception came during the
events
the Spider Island crossover but
considering that everyone in Manhattan
briefly got Spiderman powers during that
story that doesn't really count there
was however an issue of Marvel team-up
back in the late 70s where MJ was
briefly possessed by the spirit of Red
Sonja who was brought forward in time to
fight an evil wizard really though
that's just a pretty normal Tuesday for
the Marvel Universe given her prominence
in the comics it's no surprise that out
of the four big screen versions of the
spider-man story that have hit the big
screen since 2002 Mary Jane Watson has
appeared in three of them sort of she's
completely absent in the two amazing
spider-man movies from 2012 and 2014
with him a stone as Gwen Stacy serving
as the love interest in those films in
the spider-man trilogy directed by Sam
Raimi MJ is one of the most prominent
characters Kirsten Dunst co-starred in
all three films and her version of Mary
Jane provided most of the non superhero
drama she's there from Peters sad
decision to keep his identity secret in
the first movie all the way to their
relationship difficulties in the third
film made worse of course by an alien
symbiote that drove Peter to stage one
of cinema's most mean-spirited dance
numbers unfortunately all that drama led
to some criticism of the character for
being needlessly harsh toward her city
saving boyfriend MJ has also appeared in
the MCU spider-man films and way Peters
main love interest in those particularly
and far from home is Michelle played by
zendaya why are you here you don't even
have detention I know I just like coming
here to sketch people in crisis whew
it's not until the end of spider-man
homecoming that viewers learn her full
name is Michelle Jones and that her
friends call her MJ this MJ is very
different from what we've seen in the
comics but those initials are definitely
not a coincidence check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]